okay good luck to my opponent
i appreciate the hype thank you to wizzy
enjoying the stream
enjoy your resub
so this is rated rapid
let's play something normal
let's play carol i love you content
thank you less than three oh i love you
too warlick
okay carol khan time
i'll admit i don't know too much aerocon
theory but
i know enough to play the first two
moves
oh d3 has been trendy lately
where white goes for like this weird
queenless middle game
i think i'll go for g6
we'll stray away from
the main main lines
just try and get a playable position
oh and things earlier from uh druid irl
says thank you for being such a
wonderful person and inspiring my
husband and i to learn more about chess
that's very kind
okay i think i'll go for bishop g4
like the only active
logical square for the bishop
i guess bishop f5 is possible
but usually in the structure
it makes sense to trade
and then put all the pawns on light
squares
um sometimes even makes sense to play f6
maybe i'll start with knight h6
which looks weird
but
it's only way to quickly castle
i do want to open that
file so ideally the knight wants to find
a home on f5
if g4 happens i might go for this and f7
ooh pawn takes
i could also start with c5 here
or castling
calculating c5 queen b3
and queen d7
[Music]
and choices choices
yeah let's play c5
it's a move i know i want to play
try and chisel away at white structure
hey what's up lexi
good to see you
i should shout out the fellow streamers
in the chat
we have jay here
we have lexie
apologies if i'm missing anyone
yeah the ideal setup is to like have
all of my things targeting the
the white pawn center
idea to castle f6 eventually queen b6 or
queen c7
[Music]
white's probably going to try and like
reinforce everything
but already with the double pawns
hunter opens up the king could be
a
goner
doesn't show the right word there
do i know yuri krikun yes strong player
and coach actually ran into him randomly
recently
around the saint louis chess club
hey it's derek wu shout out to derek
how many ooze are there three o's
okay so the benefit of having double c
pawns
in a position like this is i can take
and after it takes i can play c5
again
i'd first need to castle and get out of
the pin
but there's going to be a lot of pawn
break potential
i don't think i'm doing a 24 hour stream
even though there's maybe some people
who want me to
in the near future i'll be doing a
12-hour stream
celebrate half million on youtube
but still about like 5 000 subs away
also okay i have a nice uh tetris piece
yeah not quite a pawn cube
there's got to be a name for this tetris
piece right it's like the s shape
it's nice thing when whenever uh
a rook pawn
captures towards the center
it becomes twice as powerful
because pawns on the very edge of the
board they only control one square but
pawns between the b and g file will
always control two squares
on top of that now my rook's sitting on
a half open file
oh a rhomboid
or a pawn parallelogram
[Music]
or a pawn cube sliced and diced
chad is so creative
wait listening to eric makes my brain
feel larger
that sounds like a serious health
condition
someone was asking earlier if you need
like a big brain to play chess
oh my opponent's gone
you do need to be present to play chess
and you need to have a stable internet
connection to play chess online
oh it's a pond snake
yeah i miss i miss playing snake on
the nokia brick phones
okay so the bishop wants to hurt me
although this pawn is defending this
pawn
oh no worries
let's be
sympathetic and give more time
oh i feel like such a nice person now
i kind of want to play c4 make a pawn
diamond
there's a rule it's like a positional
rule in chess
where
when there's bishops of a certain color
in this case we both have a dark spray
bishop
then you usually want your pawns on
opposite color of that of uh in this
case both bishops
so it'd be nice to get all my pawns on
light squares
in doing so that would fix white's pawns
on dark squares
ooh
[Music]
oh i'm threatening a cool move
oh it's probably gonna stop it though
[Music]
yeah for a moment there if it was my
move i would play bishop c1 diamond
diamonds yeah okay just for that
we have a pawn diamond
but we'll see if it's actually forever
because white might start chiseling
thank you xtempox
who is sad says are you based in chicago
i lived there for 10 years and i thought
well i saw you with other weak
i was in chicago
[Music]
about a week ago
[Music]
so it's possible you could have seen me
i've been getting recognized a decent
amount lately in public
um
a couple times recently in st louis
okay f6 maybe
it's time for f6
because i want to open that file
the thread is now takes takes takes
takes takes
to win a pawn
and if takes takes i'll double up and
f3 is probably gonna be hard to defend
okay emote only mode
let's see everyone's emotes
i still need to make like a follower
emote
twitch has a new feature where if you
follow a channel
a channel can give like every follower
one free emote
wow
[Music]
so this pawn is going in deep i have
this move
repairing this and this
if white does this and this i'll do this
this and this
okay so i'm winning a pawn
diamond is still lasting
[Music]
it might be hard to prove that this
diamond
will be forever though
[Music]
much easier to counter prove
counter proof disprove
okay bishop is fully dominating the
knight
white's position is kind of sad
if h5 i play g5
might as well move my king
white might be on zugswong eventually
also just realized i have all eight
pawns
which means i can make
eight bishops or knights
many possibilities
okay so the rook wants to
go in deep
if this rook wants to join
if a4 i probably just move back
oh a4 is probably coming
[Music]
to do this
let's start with this
i have to discourage a4
king f6
and then i'll put the rook here to
defend
i'm threatening to take on f3
oh so if rook f1
because there's also rookie 3. white has
a few moves if rook f1 i could consider
playing c5
okay now i kind of want to take and play
e5
i assume the ending is winning
okay
it's an interesting shape
it's like um
what you use to blow bubbles
like the bubble stick
or it's like a key
yeah
eat a victory i really want to take this
pawn
it's not a good move though
oh it's a pawn spoon
don't mess with my pawn spoon
the best eating utensil for
on soup
i should probably play this move
yeah like this is only i can also
consider taking but
play
or this pond spork
i don't know what shape this is anymore
it's like a
it's like a snake with a very large head
play this move first
now i'm threatening to take and
crash through
and if white takes i take with rook and
this pawns are gone
i feel like i'm getting karma for being
nice to my opponent earlier
i also feel like i shouldn't have given
them more time
his white would already be less than 30
seconds
okay try and win this based on the
position
[Music]
start with this
invade with the rook
so the point of this move is to
meet rook f2 with e3
also might just want to play this next
um might as well put my king in
h6
it's a very very pleasant position
i have a lot of time here to
do what i want
oh let's win the pawn
offer the rook trade
no mercy
now am i an onion fan
onions sometimes make me cry
but
i probably prefer onions cooked
and my diamond is still lasting forever
and ever